I'm just judging by the visionary
mathematicians over here trying to say
who got it versa I got it first your
copy of being the scooter should go
shall we what is the answer that way by
the way if you've already got there
right
you like fantastic I have proof your
next question is listen there's some
weird stuff going on here okay for
instance this exists for only a set a
certain set of values it doesn't mean
just everywhere what's the domain of law
get okay because you know obviously like
what what is a log you know when I say
log base 2 of 32 the answer of course is
but what that's kind of asking is how
long does if my growth rate is - how
long does it take me to grow up to 32
the answers are taking five Watts on on
that right now
that's a time so if I gave you log base
2 of let's do something like say a 16
okay
what's the answer this is minus 4
because again you've got a growth rate
but what you've got is some smaller than
what you started with so it's like how
long ago was at this mall who was a 1/16
the size of what I am now in the answer
as well for what at four years four
months whatever right before well now
but obviously if you ask this question
okay what's that saying how long does to
take to grow into okay so it's smaller
right
how long does how long we go was I minus
three and the answer is I was never
ministering like I was small I might
have been might have been really small
but I was never negative
okay which is why when you take this
graph you know the exists okay great
well the derivative where does that
exist
light rhetorical question where does
whatever it is
if it exists for all real values of X
but zeros okay so you kind of as a
mathematician not as notice someone
who's trying to sit a test later on in
their life a nerve as a mathematician
should ask that question what why is
that
much like now the question for rest of
you is how do I get there okay now
there's kind of a um it's kind of short
way and a slight look away and I'm gonna
show you I'll take you them along the
way because I think it it's a little
clearer okay so I'm gonna go back to
this okay this is the definition okay so
let's take something like oh I don't why
that's an original name for a function
of creational different functions of
every call at four
let's go with that now based on what
Lord means can we rewrite this in index
don't you rewrite this without any
inordinately the power of Y so the bases
are the same is equal to with only one
number left right now by the way the
fact that I said that I said well why
don't we okay there's a reason why I
made that step it wasn't just random why
didn't I go in this particular direction
any takers
okay right now let me take another step
back right remember I said when you know
something about this right that tells
you something about this okay so if I'm
trying to solve a problem with this it's
in my interest to go back to something
that I know more things about so much
advances like that right like completing
the square or you know doing the limits
it's all about taking a problem you
don't know and then short shoving it
massage it into a shape that you can
actually work with okay so I'm here now
now what can I do you can take the
shortcut
which I will show in a second or you can
take a sort of a longer putt now we're
differentiating we used to differentiate
with respect to X okay so I mean that's
fine with you okay there's the
differential operator let's whack it on
both sides okay now the first thing
that's good about this is that this
right-hand side okay I know what that is
so I'm making some progress here
right so the right-hand side obviously -
yes still awake
good job train six other Monday the
left-hand side what problem does it
produce you
with no X's that still function you can
also differentiate with respect to X but
it's not with respect to X so what can
you do
now there's two letters they write
there's an e and there's a y so what is
the left-hand side with respect to isn't
respected E or is it with respect to Y
which one
I'm gonna ask you lots of questions here
like what is the answer I won't make
this simmer - yeah and or you may not
even have heard the question its
respective with respect to why because
he is not actually it's not a variable
so you can copy with your sector really
okay so for instance I couldn't define
[ __ ]
with respect to aid because it's just a
number that's different shape with
respect to fire Billy morning like what
does that even mean okay with respect
you means something's changing so must
be variable so being that it's with
respect to block let's differentiate it
with respect to what how do I do it okay
how do I do it we're not changing what's
on the left hand side you pulled this
tree now you've been doing this for
years right you're really when you've
got something like like this
okay you're like what do I do with that
I know what to do with fractions you put
them on a common denominator but these
guys are these guys are servants
so they're like playing with each other
they're really good anti-social right so
what can you do you have to do something
to these fractures so they can mix one
what is it you have to rationalize that
how do we rationalize if I want to
rationalize you suppose fraction what
would I do to it I multiply by and it
has a name what's it cool clunky right
you should be so secret for conjugates
from last time right okay so you
multiply by the conjugate but you can't
just you can't just decide I want to
multiply by things
you're gonna divide as well certain air
changes that you have okay good yeah so
I've done the same thing down here now
that's a little weird because it's
moment number it's a differential
operator on you can still multiply and
divide by it just the same okay now how
has it made things better
what should I do here now you know if
this means differentiator right but
there's a reason it's written as a
fraction because differentiation is
about you don't rise over run that kind
of thing so being that it's a fraction
whoops what I do
I can swap the numerator job because
multiplication is found what's a cooler
is a community or is it associated this
is this is u7 but a times B is the same
as B times a my can swap them around
their produce so now here what do I do
here in this part may differentiate with
respect to Y okay so let me just make
that a bit more obvious
check this guy on the front x this okay
now I can work with this I've got do I'm
on DX at the left that's convenient
isn't it what's your dua of in the Y for
X Y you just get safely back okay so I'm
gonna divide cuz now that's what I want
the subject should be that's correct
that's fine but I want everything in
terms axes you know I introduced why
there was no y in the beginning so I
should get rid of it thankfully I know
exactly what it is it's right
so there's one last wide that I need to
get rid of maybe that one okay so let's
separate it from differential make sense
all right
that's not too hot let's just very very
quickly try out a couple of examples
okay
because really where it gets interesting
this way you start to fix it with chain
rule okay so if you were to do this what
that means
hmm he thinks that's right anyway hands
I'll straight up straight commit to it
come on don't dump you that is it isn't
right or not yes okay or I find out
therefore how can it be that two pretty
different looking functions can have the
same dance up what you think about it
can you explain why does anyone we now
have to say does anyone recognize anyone
okay keeping your head I'll cover you
that's your homework if you if you're
one of those people who are like yet I'm
sure okay your homework is to tell me
one two completely different functions
have the same if you didn't like I'm
unconvinced y'all home I kissed you
convinced to show because it is right
the question is why